let's go next to i hope i pronounced
this correctly
is it uh oh wait oh no no no this person
is actually just listening sorry sorry
sorry they don't want to be called on
that would have been a very very big
mistake
let's go next to pimbus from chicago
pimbus welcome
hi david can you hear me yes i can
how are you i'm doing well
um so i had a question on healthcare
so like i recently
broke a vertebrae in my back so i'm just
dealing with all of the
bills from the hospital and doctors and
all these different places i'm really
sorry to hear that how did that happen
i i don't know i just bent over and like
i thought i pulled something in my back
and but so we went to the i
ended up being so painful i couldn't
um get up or anything so we'd call an
ambulance anyways um the the doctor was
like you probably fell within the last
month or so and then
uh
i don't know bending over like you know
maybe you had a hairline fracture and
hanging over just kind of
did the deal but that's terrible
yeah it's honestly it's i've broken
other bones and it was the most painful
initially but the recovery has been
the fastest out of all the okay things
are broken
but uh yeah so anyways i'm just you know
dealing with all of the bills for
everything and
my dad is actually was born in france
and my both of my grandparents still
live there and his main argument against
universal health care is that
the care that his parents receive in
france is not really ideal he seems to
think that
i don't know doctors aren't paid as much
there so they're not as motivated to
provide quality care
so i'm just curious if you have any
ideas of how i could maybe dispel that
notion to him that well listen this is a
very complicated issue you know i i
can't say that much about french doctors
but i know british doctors and they are
not paid as much that is absolutely true
now whether a british doctor will
provide inferior care
because an american doctor makes more
money that also doesn't really make
sense i mean if you're british and you
work in the uk and these are the
salaries i don't know that the fact that
some doctor in new york city is getting
more money is going to make you provide
inferior care that that i'm not sure
about but i think
one of the things i would like to see
the left do is to acknowledge
that
many countries that might have better
systems than the ones that we do
they don't necessarily have perfect
systems and you have to imagine a
triangle with three you know like it's a
triangle it has three points
where there are these three elements
you've got cost quality and access
and every system is trying to make a dot
somewhere between those three
if you go
lower cost
and higher access that puts downward
pressure on quality all else being equal
if you have higher cost
and higher quality than you you're
pulling away from everybody having
access and every system is basically
trying to find a point on that triangle
and the french system is not perfect
i've talked about the german system
before we've talked about the system in
singapore there's no perfect system the
point is do we want to prioritize
quality and in quality i include the
time you have to wait until you get
treatment do we want to prioritize
quality
and or cost and or access and many
countries do better than us on any of
those three or even two of those
and then when you say well which
countries do better on all three then it
becomes a question of for what part of
the population
and i don't know that you know i don't
know enough about the french system to
say specifically
but um it is not a shock to me that no
system is perfect we've known that for a
long time
do you have like a
a system that you think in like a
certain part of the world that we should
shoot for uh you just want to be able to
give him a good example the best thing
this is so
so everybody loves to just say
single payer boom that's it it's over
i've seen
very good results with systems that are
a combination of
uh
non-profit
potentially
through employer or maybe not maybe it's
just employer subsidized but it's
non-profit and federally administered
with the option to
buy up or or buy into a private system
if you so please
with a safety net system where if you
just can't afford it you also you get
care anyway which some states in the
united states sort of have
and if i recall correctly i believe the
german system is sort of like that
but i'd have to re-up my scholarship on
the issue i've read a bunch of books
about it but it's been five years and so
i it may not be accurate to say that
it's the german system that i'm thinking
of
gotcha well thank you so much david my
pleasure absolutely great to hear from
you